so we have another signal about this
internal battle taking place
between the pro and the anti-trump wings
of the republican party
and uh it seems very clear that the
pro-trump wing is hugely winning now in
the next segment i'm going to talk about
a poll many of you emailed me about
saying look at this one poll david it
shows trump is not winning
we'll get to that uh i believe when you
look at the totality of the evidence
this is still a very very trumpy and
republican party and what we're going to
look at first here is that former
trump vice president mike pence was
brutally booed and heckled at the faith
and freedom coalition a few days ago by
fellow trumpists mind you
now how wild is it that at this point
mike pence who was simply a plant that
trump could do whatever he wanted to do
trump could water pence or not or weed
him
or pull off the flowers the guy was like
an immobile plant in the back of the
room
barely sentient during the trump
administration
pence is now widely seen as not trumpian
enough
because he didn't i guess try to steal
the election on january 6th for donald
trump via some mechanism that is still
not completely clear to me and now mike
pence is suffering the brunt of it
his career may be over or at least dead
for several
years until he can maybe rehabilitate it
check out this video of mike pence being
called a traitor
and heckled brutally mercilessly during
his attempted speech just
interruption after interruption
it is great to be back with so many
patriots
dedicated to faith and freedom
and the road to the majority
and i want to thank my friend ralph reed
for those overly generous words
i'm deeply humbled by them
ralph reed knows me well enough to know
the introduction i prefer is a little
bit shorter
i'm a christian a conservative and a
republican
in that order and i am honored to stand
before you today
there's talk of pence 2024 but if the
guy can't even get a sentence out
about i'm a christian patriot in front
of a right-wing audience
without being heckled by that very
audience it's not looking good for mike
pence
for 2024 and understand that he's being
called a traitor
because he didn't overtly try to violate
the constitution on january 6. the
people who claim to be all about the
constitution are mad
at pence because he didn't find some way
around the constitution to install trump
for a second term he didn't win
he still did trump's bidding for four
years he stood there
he nodded along he flattered trump he
said thanks to trump we did this we did
that even though it was all bs
particularly around the pandemic and
he just didn't openly try to get around
the constitution on january 6th
and now the guy's a traitor that can't
get a sentence out
now we know what pence's strategy was i
don't feel bad for pence
pence's strategy was bite his tongue
stay quiet
stay on trump's good side so that then
he could try to appropriate trump
appropriate trump's base for himself
whenever trump's done be it 2024 or
whatever the case may be
it all went in the trash with what
you could say with one act it's really a
non-act
pence abstained from trying to openly
circumvent and destroy the constitution
on january 6th
and pence is now an enemy to trumpists
plain and simple he was a good boy for
three years 11 months and two weeks
but with just two weeks left before the
end of the term he said
sir i can't steal the election
and now the guy can't get a single
sentence out
in front of a supposedly friendly
audience it is
quite stunning and i don't feel bad for
the guy
it's just amazing how reactionary and
rabid that trump base is
pence made his bed at trump's as trump's
vp and he's going to have to sleep in it
now but
a stunning series of events and also i
mean at this point
what is going on in pence's mind that he
even continues to stand up in front of
these crowds like even
religious right-wing crowds which are i
guess is bread and butter
um these are the same people some of
whom wanted him dead on january 6.
remember some of these very people
are part of the political movement that
was calling for pence to be hanged
hang mike pence was their chant on
january 6th
why even subject himself to it at this
point
i guess at least this crowd wasn't
chanting
hang mike pence at this particular event
but i see pence's political career as
completely dead
for a while let me know if you disagree
and speaking of the future of people's
political careers
let's talk about that next